the stories have been circulating for a
while now but the rumors are true
injustice to is on the way I'm Tony and
this is your super-powered gamespot news
update injustice two picks up where the
first game left off as Batman and his
allies work together to fix the problems
caused by Superman's dictatorship
developer nether realm is at the rains
again with the sequel which is said to
have a massive roster the announcement
trailer shows popular heroes like
Superman Batman and the flash duking it
out but considering the first game had
29 playable characters you can expect to
see a lot more familiar faces nether
realms at Boone also teased new features
and customization options that he says
will quote change the way fans play
fighting games injustice to is set for a
20-17 release on ps4 and Xbox one
confirmed characters so far include
those you've seen in the trailer Plus
Supergirl Atrocitus and Gorilla Grodd
you can expect plenty more character
announcements down the road so stick
with GameSpot to stay up to date on all
the news from the DC fighting universe